OF SICK TWISTED LIBERAL H
HYPOCRISY AND IVANKA TRUMP IN
THE MONOLOGUE.
BREAKING NOW, A NEW REPORT,
WASHINGTON POST, FEDERAL
PROSECUTORS INTERVIEWED JAMES
COMEY AND WEIGH WHETHER TO DIE
ANDREW McCABE WITH A CRIME FOR
HIS OBSESSIVE LYING WHICH IS WHY
HE WAS REPORT THELY --
REPORTEDLY FIRED AND THE TWO
MEMBERS OF THE DEEP STATE ARE
NOW TURNING ON EACH OTHER AND
COULD BE A SIGN OF THE WALL
COLLAPSING.
IS McCABE AND OTHERS FINALLY
GOING TO BE EXPOSED ABOUT THEIR
CONSTANT EXTREME WRONGDOING?
I SAID MANY TIMES ON THE SHOW
STARTING IN JANUARY, THIS IS THE
YEAR OF THE BOOMERANG.
WE'LL GIVE YOU THE BREAKING
DEVELOPMENTS AND TONIGHT,
ACCORDING TO REPORTS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR McCABE WHO WAS FIRED
BECAUSE OF HIS LYING WROTE A
PERSONAL CONFIDENTIAL MEMO
DETAILING HIS SO-CALLED CONCERNS
OVER THE PRESIDENT'S DECISION TO
FIRE HIS FORMER BOSS AND
PERSONAL FRIEND.
McCABE REPORTEDLY TURNED IT OVER
TO ROBERT MUELLER'S TEAM OF
WITCH HUNTERS AND HILARY
SUPPORTERS TO HELP THEIR
EFFORTS.
YOU CAN IMAGINE THE TRUMP HATING
PRESS AND THEIR FRIENDS IN THE
LEFT, THEY WERE VERY EXCITED.
SECOND BUT VERY EXCITED.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THEN WE FIND OUT THE
PRESIDENT WANTED TO FIRE COMEY
ON THE GROUNDS HE WAS CONCERNED
ABOUT THE AGGRESSIVE RUSSIA
PROBE.
IN ORDER, HE DID IT TO PROTECT-
SELF AND THIS IS CLEARLY, SEEMS
TO ME, CLOSE TO THE SMOKING GUN
OF OBSTRUCTION.
>> WE HAVE ENOUGH INFORMATION
ABOUT THIS PRESIDENT AND HIS
ATTEMPTS TO CONTROL ROSENSTEIN
AND JEFF SESSIONS AND TO
LITERALLY HAVE THEM PROTECT HIM
FROM THIS INVESTIGATION.
I THINK IT IS CLEAR THAT HE'S
OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE.
>> THE QUESTION ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT AND COMEY'S FIRE HAS
BEEN WHAT DID IT MEAN ABOUT THE
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION.
>> HE'S ONE OF THE PEOPLE DONALD
TRUMP HAS BEEN HAMMERING THAT HE
DOESN'T TRUST AND SUCH BUT IF HE
TRIED TO GIVE HIM COVER, A COVER
STORY TO FIRE COMEY, TALK ABOUT
REPAYING A FAVOR.
JUST SAYING -- THAT'S AMAZING
HOW THIS IS ALL TURNING OUT.
>> Sean: AMAZING HOW DUMMY
SO-CALLED COLLEAGUES IN THIS
INDUSTRY ARE.
YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT A REAL NEWS
STORY, MORE LIES AND BREATHLESS
REPORTING OF SO-CALLED NEWS.
WHILE McCABE EXPRESSED CONCERNS
OF TRUMP FIRING COMEY, HERE'S
WHAT THEY'RE NOT TELLING YOU,
THE PRESIDENT HAD THE FULL
AUTHORITY TO FIRE COMY EY
AUTHORITY TO FIRE COMY E
AUTHORITY TO FIRE COMY FO
AUTHORITY TO FIRE COMY FOR
AUTHORITY TO FIRE COMY FOR A
AUTHORITY TO FIRE COMY FOR ANY
WHEREIN.
HE SAID HE HAD THE RIGHT TO FIRE
THAT'S FAKE NEWS.
THAT'S HYSTERIA AND OUTRIGHT
LYING TO YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THIS COMES AFTER OUR OWN ADAM
HOUSLEY REPORTED McCABE
ALLEGEDLY THREATENED TO TAKE
DOWN OTHERS IF FIRED AND THIS
MEMO PROVIDES LITERALLY NO
EVIDENCE THE PRESIDENT DID
ANYTHING WRONG.
IT REVEALS SOMETHING ELSE.
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL, ROB
ROSENSTEIN HE TALKED ABOUT
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE FIRING
OF COMEY AND THIS MEANS ROB
ROSENSTEIN IS A WITNESS TO THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S INVESTIGATION.
WITNESS ONE, THE VERY
INVESTIGATION HE'S OVERSEEING
AND HE'S EVEN MORE COMPROMISED
THAN WE THOUGHT.
HOW IS IT POSSIBLE AGAIN THE
JEFF SESSIONS REUSED  -- RECUSED
HIMSELF CITING THE LONG LAW AND
ROB ROSENSTEIN IS NOT
CONFLICTED?
HE ALSO SIGNED THE FINAL FISA
WARRANT AND PUT HIS SIGNATURE ON
IT WITH THE BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
HILLARY CLINTON DOSSIER AND
RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA A FOREIGN
AGENT USING LICE  -- LIES TO LIE
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ONE MORE
STEP IN THE FLAWED WITCH HUNT.
IT NEEDS TO END.
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, HAVE
PAID MORE THAN $16 MILLION TO
FUND THIS PARTISAN EFFORT AND
FOR WHAT?
379 DAYS WOULD PROOF AND JOHN
SALOMON WILL JOIN US WITH NEW
INFORMATION AND DETAILS ON
SERIOUS AND SHOCKING ABUSE OF
POWER.
HE'LL BE HERE IN MOMENT TO
PREVIEW THE UPCOMING BOMBSHELL
REPORT REVEALING IN 2016 THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION PRESSURED
THE FBI TO RAMP UP THEIR SPYING
OPERATIONS AGAINST THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND ADMINISTRATION.
A MASSIVE EXCLUSIVE.
YESTERDAY IN THE WASHINGTON
TESTIMONY FROM FUSION GPS
FOUNDER, GLEN SIMPSON AND SAID,
QUOTE, THE FBI HAD A HUMAN
SOURCE INSIDE THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
OKAY, THAT WAS WAY BACK IN 2017.
DON'T FORGET LAST WEEK, FORMER
CIA DIRECTOR TURNED CNN HACK,
JAMES CLAPPER, ACTUALLY SAID
TRUMP SHOULD BE SO HAPPY THE FBI
WAS SPYING ON HIS CAMPAIGN.
REALLY?
OKAY?
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA OR
VENEZUELA?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I ASK YOU, WAS THE FBI SPYING
ON TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN?
>> THEY WERE NOT.
THEY WERE SPYING -- I TERM I
DON'T PARTICULARLY LIKE ON WHAT
THE RUSSIANS WERE DOING TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND IF THE RUSSIAN
TRYING TO GAIN ACCESS AND
LEVERAGE AND INFLUENCE.
>> SO WHY DOESN'T HE LIKE THAT?
HE SHOULD BE HAPPY.
>> HE SHOULD BE.
>> WHY DIDN'T YOU GO TO HIM IN
THE SPRING OF 2016 AND SAID
THERE'S A GUY YOU NEVER MET
WE'RE WATCHING.
HE WOULD HAVE HELPED YOU.
THE MOST EVIDENCE IS THAT THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN WAS MONITORED AND
CLOSELY OBSERVED BY THE DEEP
STATE HELL BENT ON MAKING SURE
NEVER BECAME THE PRESIDENT.
A MAJOR ABUSE OF POWER ALL
UNRAVELLING.
AND CLAPPER IS NOW ACTUALLY IN A
TWISTED DISTORTED WAY BLAMING
REPUBLICANS FOR DISRUPTING
EFFORTS FOR FAILING TO WARN THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
REMEMBER THE NUNEZ WASHINGTON
EXAMINER PIECE, TAKE A LOOK.
>> THERE WAS CONCERN ON THE PART
OF THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF
ALLEGATIONS OF RIGGING CANDIDATE
TRUMP WAS THEN ESPOUSING THAT
THAT ANYTHING THE PRESIDENT
WOULD BE DOING WOULD BE TO THE
DISFAVOR OF ANOTHER.
I THINK BEN'S EXACTLY RIGHT AND
MY BOOK COMPORTS WITH HIS
ACCOUNT.
>> HE SAID BUT NOT FOR MITCH
McCONNELL PERHAPS THERE WOULD
HAVE BEEN MORE SAID.
DOES MITCH McCONNELL STAND IN
THE WAY?
>> THE REPUBLICANS IN GENERAL
DID.
IT'S COUNTER RELUCTANCE ON THEIR
PART TO ENTER INTO AN AGGRESSIVE
STATEMENT ABOUT THE RUSSIANS.
>> REALLY?
MAYBE MR. CLAPPER SHOULD READ
THE 2016 REPORT FROM NBC NEWS
ENTITLED WHY DID OBAMA DO MORE
ABOUT RUSSIAN ELECTION HACKING.
THEY DIDN'T ACT BECAUSE THEY
THOUGHT HILLARY CLINTON WAS
GOING WIN AND A POTENTIAL CYBER
WAR WITH RUSSIA WASN'T WORTH IT.
LOOKS LIKE CLAPPER IS THERE AT
CNN FAKE NEWS.
HE GETS PAID AND WHILE CLAPPER
AND EVERYONE ELSE IN THE DEEP
STATE TRIES TO DRAG THE
PRESIDENT DOWN, THE PRESIDENT
HAS BEEN UP TO SERIOUS BUSINESS
TO ACTUALLY ATTEMPT TO ON THE
WORLD STAGE -- IMPORTANT THINGS
TO WORLD PEACE AND THE UPCOMING
TALK WITH THE NORTH KOREAN
DICTATOR, LITTLE ROCKET MAN, KIM
JONG-UN AND MIKE POMPEO HELD A
MEETING WITH THE HIGH-RANKING
MEMBER OF THE NORTH KOREAN
REGIME FOR THE FIRST TIME IN 18
YEARS ON U.S. SOIL AND THIS IS
WHAT MIKE POMPEO HAD TO SAY.
>> WE DISCUSSED HOW OUR
COUNTRIES CAN COME TOGETHER AND
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE TWO
OPPORTUNITY THE TWO LEADERS HAVE
CREATED THROUGH THEIR VISION OF
THE FUTURE THEY HAVE ARTICULATE.
THE PROPOSED SUMMIT OFFERS A
HISTORIC OFFERING TO BOLDLY LEAD
THE UNITED STATES INTO A NEW ERA
OF PEACE, PROSPERITY AND
SECURITY.
AND THERE COULD BE NOTHING SHORT
OF TRAGIC TO LET THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO WASTE.
IF KIM JONG-UN DENUCLEARIZES
THERE'S A BRIGHTER PATH FOR
NORTH KOREA.
WE SEE A STRONG NORTH KOREA THAT
MAINTAINS ITS HERITAGE BUT
INTEGRATED
INTEGRATE
INTEGRATED  INTO THE COMMUNITY
OF NATION.
>> Sean: HE IS SET TO MEET WITH
AN OFFICIAL AND WILL BE
DELIVERING A LETTER HIMSELF.
>> WE'RE DOING WELL WITH NORTH
KOREA.
OUR SECRETARY OF STATE HAS HAD
GOOD MEETINGS.
HE'S MEETING AGAIN TODAY.
I BELIEVE THEY'LL BE COMING DOWN
TO WASHINGTON ON FRIDAY AND A
LET SER GOING  -- LETTER IS
GOING TO BE DELIVERED TO ME FROM
KIM JONG-UN SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
WHAT'S IN THE LETTER.
HOPEFULLY WE'LL HAVE A MEETING
ON THE 12th GOING ALONG WELL.
I WANT IT TO BE MEANINGFUL.
MAYBE IT DOESN'T ALL GET DONE IN
ONE MEETING AND PERHAPS WE'LL
NEED A SECOND OR THIRD BUT IT'S
IN GOOD HANDS.
>> Sean: AS THE PRESIDENT
MANAGED THE ONGOING NEGOTIATIONS
WITH NORTH KOREA HE'S BEEN
MAKING WAVES AT HOME AND GOOD
WAVES.
TODAY THE PRESIDENT PARDONED
CONSERVATIVE ACTIVIST
CONSERVATIVE ACTIVIST DINISH
D'SOUSA
D'SOUS
D'SOUSA AND HE IS CONSIDERING A
PARDON OF MARTHA STEWART AND
PERHAPS BLAGOJEVICH AND THEY
WERE SPINNING OUT OF CONTROL
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT IS USING
HIS ABSOLUTE POWER OF THE
PARDON.
HE HAS THE RIGHT TO DO WHATEVER
HE WANTS ON THIS.
TOO BAD.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS SEND MESSAGE
TO PEOPLE LIKE PAUL MANAFORT AND
MICHAEL
MICHAE
MICHAEL FLYNN.
THOSE THE QUESTIONS.
>> HE'S THROWING A MEAT TO THE
BONE AND
BONE AN
BONE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS THROWING
THEM OUT LIKE OPRAH GIFTED
PONTIACS TO SUBURB BAN MOMS.
>> THESE ARE THINGS WE SEE FROM
BANANA REPUBLIC.
>> HE'S PARDONING D'SOUZA AND
CONSIDERING LENIENCY FOR TWO
STARS OF HIS FORMER TV SHOWS
MAKE
MAK
MAKING THIS WHITE HOUSE SEEMED
DETACHED FROM REALITY.
>> DRUG DEALERS, OBAMA.
WE DON'T NEED LECTURES FROM
THESE PEOPLE.
LEAVE IT TO THE MEDIA TO TOTALLY
IGNORE THE MASSIVE ABUSE OF
POWER THAT TOOK PLACE DURING THE
PROSECUTION OF DAESHGS
D'SOUZA AND HE WAS PROSECUTED
AND TAKE THE CASE OF MARTHA
STEWART.
PROSECUTORS TRIED TO SEND HER TO
PRISON FOR AN INSIDER TRADING
CHARGE IN ORDER, SHE HAD A SPOT
TRANSACTION.
WENT AFTER HER FOR OBSTRUCTION
AND DON'T FORGET SCOOTER LIBBY
THE PUBLIC SERVANT WITH THE BOOK
THROWN AT HIM OVER AN ALLEGED
UNPROVEN LEAK WHEN THEY KNEW WHO
THE LEAKER WAS THE FIRST DAY
THEY TOOK OVER THE CASE.
THE STRONGARM TACTICS TO ELICIT
GUILTIES FROM INDIVIDUALS
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T GET THEM ON
THE CHARGE THEY'RE
INVESTIGATING.
IT DESERVES A CONVERSATION IN
THE COUNTRY BY THE DOUBLE
STANDARD IN THE TRUMP-HATING
MEDIA AND COMPARE THIS TO JAMES
COMEY AND PETER STRZOK AND LISA
PAGE AND LORETTA LYNCH AND BILL
CLINTON.
THERE WERE 33,000 DELETED
SUBPOENAED E-MAILS ON A PRIVATE
SERVER AND HILLARY CLINTON
COVERED IT UP AND OBSTRUCTED BY
DELETING THEM AND THE ACID WATCH
AND THE BREAKING UP OF DEVICES
BY HAMMERS.
I SAY FREE MARTHA STEWART AND
COMPARED TO SANDY BURGER.
HE STOLE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
FROM THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES AND
STUCK THEM IN HIS PADS AND
SOCKS.
HE NEVER GOT CHARGED WITH A
CRIME.
CAN YOU SAY A TWO TIERED JUSTICE
SYSTEM?
WHAT HAPPENED TO EQUAL JUSTICE
AND EQUAL APPLICATION TO THE
LAW?
WHAT HAPPENS TO OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS WE'RE ALL
EQUAL IN THIS COUNTRY?
FINALLY TONIGHT, A STORY FROM A
SO-CALLED MEDIAN NAMED SAMANTHA
BEE.
LISTEN SO WHAT SHE HAD TO SAY
ABOUT IVANKA TRUMP.
IT WILL MAKE YOU PUKE BUT IT WAS
ON TBS LAST NIGHT.
>> IVANKA TRUMP WHO WORKS AT THE
WHITE HOUSE CHOSE TO POSE THE
SECOND MOST OBLIVIOUS TWEET
WE'VE SEEN.
THAT'S A BEAUTIFUL FOETDO
THAT'S A BEAUTIFUL FOETD
THAT'S A BEAUTIFUL --ETD
THAT'S A BEAUTIFUL -- PD
THAT'S A BEAUTIFUL -- PHO
THAT'S A BEAUTIFUL -- PHOTO
THAT'S A BEAUTIFUL -- PHOTO O
THAT'S A BEAUTIFUL -- PHOTO OF
YOU AND YOUR CHILD BUT DO
SOMETHING ABOUT YOUR DAD'S
IMMIGRATION PRACTICES YOU
[BLEEP] [BLEEP].
HE LISTENS TO YOU.
PUT ON SOMETHING LOW CUT AND
TELL YOUR FATHER TO STOP IT AND
TELL HIM IT WAS AN OBAMA THING.
>> Sean: ONE MORE BLATANT
EXAMPLE IF YOU'RE A LIBERAL IN
THE PUBLIC SPOTLIGHT YOU CAN DO
AND SAY ANYTHING YOU WANT AND NO
CONSEQUENCES.
THE OPPOSITE IS TRUE FOR
CONSERVATIVES.
WE JUST SAW ROSEANNE'S SHOW
CANCELED FOR HER COMMENTS BUT
FOR SAMANTHA BEE SHE SAID I
WOULD SINCERELY APOLOGIZE TO
IVANKA TRUMP AND TO MY VIEWERS
FOR USING AN EXPLETIVE, LOOK,
LET ME BE CLEAR.
I DON'T CALL FOR BOYCOTTS OR FOR
PEOPLE TO BE SILENCED, I DON'T
WANT SHOWS CANCELED.
I'M NOT CALLING FOR ANYBODY TO
BE FIRED, DO YOU THINK SHE'S A
NOT FUNNY BITTER PARTISAN
MINDLESS HACK, TURN THE CHANNEL.
DON'T HAVE TO WATCH HER HATEFUL
ONE MORE EXAMPLE OF WHAT SAY